i think the assumption comes from the
belief that um
it'll just be exactly like it was last
year you know i think that's what you
gotta
not fall into is that oh this is the way
it worked last year so
this is the way it'll be this year and
the reality is everything's different
the teams will approach you a little bit
differently you know you're kind of the
team everyone's watching now so
there's different degrees of expectation
there's more external
noise there'll be more people that are
wanting to come to games
um more opportunity to do things outside
of football
and i think the reality is you got to
stay focused on
um you know what's really important how
do you improve how do you get better
from week to week
day to day even the games you know a lot
of games we won last year were very
razor thin margins um one or two plays
you know make the difference in every
game so
i'm you know from from how i feel about
it
and how ba has talked about it with our
team he's done a great job of keeping us
focused um keeping the intensity there
allowing us to continue to work out
together and communicate
and make improvements that we need to
make because i feel like you know we're
not finished products
and it was really our first opportunity
to play together last year
and there's a lot of opportunity for us
to grow into something that could be
you know very different we have a lot of
guys who like to do that very
competitive
group of guys
no nfl team has repeated as super bowl
champions since the 2003-2004 patriots
and i distinctly recall in 2004
one of the ingredients to the patriots
being as good as they were
people didn't believe they were good
enough to repeat
they just kept chugging along but they
weren't regarded
you're right as this the team right
all the starters back and everything's
lined up and the buccaneers are great
and maybe they'll go 17-0
you're right the patriots didn't have
that so they were able to have the chip
on their shoulder that propelled them
to what was regarded as unlikely it
makes it even harder for the buccaneers
and chris as we said yesterday
up 2810 tom brady turns into an
interception machine
and but for the decision to not go for
it and the packers don't force overtime
the packers
could have and should have won that game
they had all the momentum
very different narrative around brady
and the buccaneers if that's ultimately
what happens
maybe they don't hold the team together
you know it's a deflating end
guys are going to need a fresh start etc
um
i i i agree with everything he's saying
it's not gonna be easy and it's gonna
require
every ounce of his leadership abilities
to keep everyone focused all year long
one week at a time
on getting back to where they just were
yeah no i mean it is it is
interesting again i think it's another
it's going to be a great like
psychological experiment
to a degree because like it's unique in
them the fact that
you know they were a good team all year
they really didn't become a really good
team
and start to come together to the last
you know
two three games of the regular season
into the playoffs
so like them playing at a really high
level is still going to be new to them
which i think would add like excitement
to be like wait wait i mean we just got
going let's go all of that
you know i also think with with ba bruce
aryans and the culture around there i
don't think they're gonna feel the
pressure of the situation
i think he's a great guy to keep people
loose and
kind of just enjoy you know the the the
riches of being the kings of football
and all that
but yeah i mean everything brady said is
true not that i can speak to being on
the super bowl team but i can speak to
being on a good team one year
and then coming back to the next year
and going
wait we're doing all the same things we
did last year but
none of it's working and why can't we do
it as good
in those type of things every team every
year has its own lifeline
and even with brady and some of those
teams like that they won super bowls
with
there was one year they hey yeah man the
tight end stuff it's all great we're
killing the nfl
the next year yeah teams make
adjustments all of a sudden they're all
over the tight end stuff and you have to
go like
wait we kind of got to reinvent
ourselves to find our new niche for this
season to kind of like
what we are what makes us go oh hey
here's wes welker edelman let's start to
do that part of the offense
that is a real thing and they're going
to have to find that you know little
rhythm with the 20 21 bucks
because yeah it's unlikely that they're
just going to hit the ground running
doing exactly what they did at the end
of last year
and be able to execute that because you
and i both know like brady said
everybody studies the super bowl winner
everybody they're all going to watch it
and then especially the teams that are
going to play them early in the year and
the division teams
so some of the things that they were
bread and butter good at last year
teams are going to make adjustments let
alone they got a bullseye and they're
the super bowl champs and everyone who
wants a piece of their ass when you're
when you're that team
it's the measuring stick game on
everyone's schedule yes the one that
gets circled
and especially early in the year you
know if the buccaneers end up stumbling
at all then it's not as big of a deal in
november december but early in the year
that's what the cowboys are gearing up
for this is their chance to reestablish
themselves and get their season off to a
great start and they would love nothing
more than to go to tampa bay
and win on the night where they raise
their banner so
yeah every team every opponent there in
the division out of the division in the
conference out of the conference they
all are going to want
to show what they can do against the
tampa bay buccaneers the bucks are going
to get the best of what every team they
face has every given week especially as
long as they are still
a good team wheels come off different
story altogether
the folks at points bet don't expect the
wheels to come off for the buccaneers or
the kansas city chiefs they are the
overwhelming favorites
to win the super bowl the chiefs plus
475
the buccaneers plus 650 and then there
is a
gap plus 1200 are the bills and the rams
i'm surprised the rams are as high as
they are but when you go out and get
matthew stafford and you're already a
final eight team
and you're replacing jared goff with
matthew stafford i understand it i still
am surprised that the rams are higher
than the 49ers at plus 1300 but there's
a
regardless there's a gap between the
chiefs and the bucks
and the rest of the top contenders i
would think the rams thing above the
49ers like yeah i'm with you it's a
little surprising at first look but i
would guess it's all about the
quarterback really like you said
it's just the stafford and we're not
sure jimmy g trey lance whatever how do
they feel about it
i would believe that's the perception
but i don't know i mean
you know i i'm like when i look at those
i go i feel it's about right
i mean i do think kansas city and tampa
bay just on paper and everything like
that
are a notch above the rest of the nfl
right now you know one with like
their mental toughness uh you know their
showmanship
and then of course they're talented and
we've talked so much about the
bucks and how amazing it is that 22
starters are back
but like we're seeing a team that's gone
to the super bowl two years in a row and
yeah lost this last one
but got significantly better this
offseason like significant and i feel
like it's kind of been
swept under the rug because of the
buccaneers thing and they had lost and
all those type of things
but man when you talk about what they
did on the offensive line right mike
they got geron reed one of the better d
tackles in football who said screw you
seattle i don't want to be here if you
want to renegotiate my contract
for what like seven million dollars to
get him
you know and then made some other moves
with my cues and things like that to
where i just go
yeah don't sleep on the chiefs they
didn't like sit back and go oh we just
got to play better this year
or have a new execution standpoint from
what we did in the super bowl
they they got better they got players to
get better
and that's where i look at those two
teams is certainly the cream of the crop
a point that someone made to me after
the falcons traded receiver julio jones
to the tennessee titans making the
titans
dramatically better and thrusting them i
think into the elite they're already
close to the elite in the afc
this is gonna be a lot like last year
and it may even be more pronounced
where it's murderers row in the afc
and who are the buccaneers really
competing with i mean
look after the bucks it's the it's the
rams
right i've it's bucks versus rams i'll
take the bucks
right now um i know maybe between the
batteries have an easier path
definitely all their dysfunction right
whether roger shows up or doesn't show
up
the packers going 13-3 again this year i
don't think so
but it could be the bucks have an easier
path in the regular season
i mean they're going to face the falcons
twice now without julio jones who has
done well against them in the past they
have an easier path in the regular
season
greater likelihood of being the top seed
they did the hard way last year going on
the road every week in the playoffs
maybe this year they end up the one seed
saints are in transition without drew
brees
but but the afc is going to have that
cluster of great teams
so by the time you get to the last game
how much gas will the chiefs have left
in the tank if it is the chiefs
and the buccaneers they won't be as
battle hardened but they also won't be
down
four or five starters who got banged up
throughout the course of the afc
post season so it's another reason to
look at the buccaneers and say
yeah you're sitting pretty you know
they're they're in a good spot
there's no there's no like you're right
there's no team in the nfc you really
look at and go
they got it all they're dominant watch
out for them this year
there's really not you're right i mean
new orleans we know is good but
it's a transition to a degree you know
the 49ers i think we look at them as
maybe
uh the complete roster to have the type
of talent
you know to mess with the box they can
stay healthy if they can stay healthy
right which we're already seeing issues
with that this week
and then of course the quarterback
conversation but the afc as we brought
up a few times in the last few weeks
you're right it's unbelievable and
forget about that too
it's it's all the great quarterbacks in
the afc i mean they're they're all over
there
other than brady russell wilson and
rogers i mean when you just start to
break it down i mean just the afc north
all those studs
josh allen you know new england the jets
with a top five pick the afc south has
got
wence and tannehill and deshaun watson
now trevor lawrence
gets added to the mix i mean mahomes
herbert
i mean just everything you look at it
you're right it's not going to be easy
to get out of the afc and that certainly
could be a factor
uh for for the chiefs as they go along
through the year
you know the nfc team if i'm the
buccaneers i'd be the most concerned
about which which team in the nfc has
the formula
to beat tommy in in a single elimination
game which team has the formula
well you you thinking about the the
g-men
no then no single close
close go down 95 a little bit who'd we
who did we praise yesterday
washington oh wow oh no doubt they got
the formula you're right
you're right i'm not going to sleep on
washington you're exactly right they got
it they got
they got the stuff
to make tommy's life a living hell
agreed
agreed they do they have some potential
there to be a player i'm with you and
you know as we stated yesterday we're
both taking washington to win the nfc
east
i don't i don't it's a no-brainer for me
yeah i mean i like what the giants did
and things like that but man i think
that washington team like we
like you talked about front four can win
win games by themselves and then you
have all those guys in coverage and that
offense with the weapons and things like
that yeah they're definitely one of
those teams i think yeah
we should watch out for they got the
offense to keep up with whatever brady
can do and they got the defense to keep
brady from doing what he can
do and that knee i'm telling you he
keeps talking about that knee he said
that knee bothered him since april may
of last year
he had to deal with it all season long
and they're going to use
shotgun more to protect it who's to say
that it's fine they didn't tell us it
wasn't fine last year
and speaking of fine he keeps talking
about that knee they are getting fined
because he never was on the injury
report last year with a knee
never not a single time and he's now
made it clear and he keeps talking about
it just like brett favre talked about
his partially torn biceps tendon
in 2009 when he went to the vikings they
eventually went back and they find the
jets
and mike tannenbaum and eric mangini for
not disclosing that injury
the bucks have to worry about that
because he just keeps talking about it
and it makes me wonder how bad it was
and it makes me wonder chris
how good it really is and will be not a
conspiracy it's a fact yeah
i mean listen i i uh no i i think it's
you know
your crusades about the injury reports
are always great but like this is real
i don't know like to me it seems like
does the nfl care anymore maybe they
don't care
i i just feel like better they've kind
of let a few of these
scenarios kind of just fall by the way
side uh
lately i do and yeah the brady thing i
mean honestly
come on this has been talked about since
february i mean
every every other week there's a
conversation about his knee being hurt
last year and
man he had to play through it and all of
that so i mean if there was somebody to
get fined yeah you would think it would
be the bucks and the champs and tom
brady and all that but i don't know
maybe the nfl has
has stopped worrying about it because
what this is at least the third or
fourth time we've talked about
you know somebody who was injured that
we didn't know about in the last six or
seven weeks
well they're going to wake up one day
and roger goodell is going to have a
date with a
senate or house committee that's what's
going to testify on
integrity and professional sports as it
relates to the
transparency or lack thereof of
information available to bettors and
access to inside information and other
assorted means for potential corruption
they're going to be surprised then
potentially but they shouldn't be
because that's where all this is going
to lead all the billions they're going
to make off of gambling
it's going to come with a price if they
don't take care of some of these issues
and that's one of the ones that they
need to care about or it's going to
haunt them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports